so left behind is a prequel to a Last of
Us and it's like going in it right away
I was like I kind of have some idea of
where this is going to go because we
know Ellie story already so what are
like the storytelling hurdles you have
to overcome when people who have played
it have this inkling of where it's
headed yeah that's that's that's a good
question because that's something that
we challenged ourselves when we first
started working on left behind which is
what is this telling me that I didn't
already know before like you know Ellie
speech at the end you kind of know at
least faith and Riley's faith coming out
of this thing so what is it about the
journey the bond the relationship of
these two characters that kind of helped
define both of them and you get to see
them go through an arc like when you
meet Elian left behind she's a pretty
different person and who she is at the
beginning of the main campaign and
likewise the other thing that was
intriguing us about the story is for
Joel you get to see the event that kind
of broke am shaped who he was when you
start the main campaign with Ellie you
don't get to see it she's already on
that journey she's already been bitten
so is there really interesting for us to
explore what does it like to live in
this quarantine zone in this post
pandemic world where it's kind of a
horrible existence and yet you still
have kids and trying to be kids yeah so
it's where's the end of this there's big
big big kiss and I already know this is
going to be like the headline story of
like every website because we have we
have to talk about this there's a
teenage girl kissing another teenage
girl like do you see this as
controversial are you fearing any kind
of backlash from this hearing backlash
yes no there's no fear at all I guess we
just know we know there's going to be
some of that and that's one of the
things you know we're working and we
really challenged ourselves to say is
this essential to the story did you go
to the right because you could tell the
same story just cut that moment down
actually we tried that we tried cutting
it out and it just felt like it wasn't
as strong it wasn't I didn't get to know
these characters in the same level so
for us it was imperative to tell this
story
as far as it should it be controvert I
don't think it should be like riley
friday was a boy I don't think we'd be
talking about it really no I wouldn't
yeah yeah one of the interesting things
about this is that there it you still
play through most of it but most a lot
of the playing is just exploration as
opposed to the combat centric the last
of us it was that was that late because
that's a tough step because we already
have like gone home is in a game like we
already have people talking about like
games they don't have a lot of combat as
not being real games is do you see
yourself moving more in that direction
and more comfortable with that direction
of you can just exist in a world and
it's still totally interesting and fun
as all the other emotions you'd want
yeah that's that's the challenge with
with that for us again because we're
making an action game is how do you
build mechanics and how do you not just
make everything a one-off you know with
the last of us we really challenge
ourselves to go with fewer combats than
we've done in the past we went past our
comfort zone with that and we felt
because of that there was more tension
in the situations and with the DLC we
said okay let's try to go even further
let's see if we could do fewer combat
but we still refine the comment we know
we still added like the the three-way
kind of factions where you can have
infected fighting other humans and you
can kind of choose whether you want to
skirt around them or set them off
against each other so there was more
depth more more options in the combat
while at the same time because there are
fewer set pieces hopefully there's more
attention to those situations so you
mentioned like when you're making the
last times you never established what
Ellie's terrible past was but when you
when you wrote the last of us did you
have this whole kind of scenario in mind
already like the rough sketch even who
wasn't in the game yeah I mean we knew
like the rough kind of main beats of
like they were together at the mall they
got bitten you know she talks about
Riley Riley dying and she didn't and she
was struggling with that at the same
time I was writing with faith Aaron
Hicks the last of us American Dreams
graphic novel that you know his cannon
so then when it was time to do the Left
Behind story it seemed like a good fit
where he could kind of continue that
what started
graphic novel and kind of filling that
gap and you get to see this this moment
that really changed le forever yeah I
clearly really like the storytelling cuz
I mean you see as you just said like
Riley assumes I she almost felt like a
big sister the way that she nudged her
as opposed to like Joel Joel more like
ordered her a little more where's Riley
was clearly in charge but didn't feel
like she was forcing her I thought so I
did think that was really interesting
how it the how we do see her growth to
just be this independent young woman in
those scenes where she can actually
choose for herself I thought she was a
very interesting character if you
haven't noticed already we we like her
too yeah I mean do you ever worry that
like because I had the audience for this
is so much male dominated with the
triple-a stuff you ever worry that
having a Karen that that's actually not
very true that is actually what it was
what is your experience what is like the
breakdown for like it's the last morning
6044 males are you know there's a
60-percent male audience but i believe
it's forty percent okay so so I mean
what kind of responses are you getting
from like having le being so I mean cuz
she she was I mean it was her and the
woman Jodi from beyond two souls I
thought were the strongest characters
all year and it just happened to be
women also so what kind of reactions are
you getting that you're exploring this
after you know it was Nathan Drake and
it was Jack and it was all male
characters for that I think the
reception's been great and I mean we
never set out to really make a statement
so much is like maybe play with tropes
and make a super capable character said
it's almost like you know the
understanding is like the
generalizations right I was like oh
she's going to be it's going to be an
escort mission and we went out of our
way to to make her the most capable and
independent and feisty you know person
that she could be which then it's the
contrast with Joel's you know he he's
resistant and reluctant to let somebody
end
and so you needed that contrast you
needed somebody like kind of banging on
the door emotionally physically and
capably and to also win over not only
Joel but the players we wanted to make
sure that players felt like Ellie's
awesome like oh she just threw a brick
in an opportune time to help me and
she's saying jokes that I think are all
like there's every single turn we tried
to give her moments and make her stand
out on her own yeah and like Bruce is
saying we really like playing with
convention so it's like you have the
hardened gritty guy that ends up having
all these emotional breakdowns kind of
like going against that character and
then you have saved yeah and how many
times was he actually saved by Ellie
sure and then you have like the person
that you think you're going to escort
and like even in the main campaign
throughout winter it looks like Joel's
going in and he's gonna be the one that
saves le in the last second and Ellie
saves herself she actually doesn't need
him so that was kind of like yeah that
was a large part of it and we saw that
time and again we were just at PAX
recently you know we had to do a silly
signing where we're sending some posters
or something but we would ask like all
the fans we tried out like what was your
favorite part and i would say nine out
of ten people said winter when you play
as ellie i would vote for winter also so
you know hopefully with left behind that
continues and they really enjoy
character like this because we find an
intriguing it's not an agenda but by all
means like we're happy that people
resonate with the character and we're
happy that it does make a statement I
mean there's no that there's no reason
why this should be like it's the same
thing with you know yeah sexual
identities etc it's like who cares good
characters a good character yeah that's
what we're after here
the MU the mood of the game was really
interesting to me because it's it's
really light-hearted which sounds
strange because it's the zombie
apocalypse but like you're in a
Halloween store you know you Riley and
Ellie and they're laughing and it's it's
actually genuinely funny too and you're
kind of laughing along with them but
like in the back of my mind was fear all
the time because like fear of the
inevitable and fear of where they're
living and what kind of world are living
and it was that was that saying you were
trying to inject was was that feeling
the whole time or you're trying to have
like just levity in the last of us
universe I think it's interesting that
just the nature of the world brings that
tension just inherently I think we all
kind of have that like what's around the
next corner sort of feeling in that just
seeing you know an abandoned mall where
people are supposed to be like flooded
through there and shopping and happy
you're supposed to hear that noise and
then it's you know you hear birds
twittering often trees and and there's
that kind of awkward silence inside of
the the mall it's trying to put your
soft pudding and you're trying to put
stuff in the mind of like what would it
be like to live in this situation
regularly so that you could get used to
it and then you see Riley plays off of
that as well as you know she could get a
rise out of Le by scaring her so and
again in that scenario in that setting
how can you find a moment of fun a
moment of levity yeah yeah I mean it's
definitely one of the things even though
the tensions already kind of built in
with the world it was like our direct
intention to say okay let's let's have
fun let's be a couple teenagers like
hanging out you know in a mall turning
power on and trying to escape it's like
cause the thing that teenagers would do
in our world what's the metaphor for
that in this world